I did watch some Netflix documentaries
though okay of course I did and there's
one that I kind of want to talk about
it's kind of interesting
um it was about I don't know if you
heard about this there was a guy in
Denmark who made like his own submarine
okay he uh ended up killing someone on
the submarine right but he was always
like he's a pretty famous guy in Denmark
he's pretty quirky he's called like
Peter like very quirky okay
commit murder okay
um and I got this documentary was
interesting because the documentary crew
is actually following him for all the
weird [__] he was doing yeah generally
and during the documentary the filming
of it is when he killed someone yeah oh
sure so it's it's one of the like
obviously like this can never happen
because you couldn't have he you
couldn't be like hey that's just film
gone in case he murders someone so that
we have the crew ready to go yeah so
like it's it's like an hour and a half
customer the chase it's really good it's
really just like if you want to see a
documentary about like True Crime
whatever even though it doesn't really
focus on that too much it's just kind of
like showing you the sheer shock of
everyone around the the guy the who did
this [__] up thing
watching this documentary and just
seeing how
this this dude who had built himself up
and was really respected by all these
people who are working with him as like
unpaid interns yeah they all just worked
with him to help make these submarines
for free because they just believed in
it and they're all very close they're
all very close-knit and then he murders
someone and how does he murder them he
so he go he takes this journalist out on
on the submarine and then suddenly the
he comes back up and there's no
journalist on board and then there's a
lot of questions that are like what what
happened right why is that why is the
journalist not on board with you
everybody saw you leave with the
journalist and he's like oh no no she's
fine and everyone's like what what do
you what do you mean and then so they
arrest him because they assumed that
Something's Happened yeah yeah and then
a few days later half a body turns up on
the on like a coastline
and then he says like oh well the the
hatch dropped on her head and I then
shocking and then he and then he
admitted to cutting up the body but he
said yeah I didn't kill her you know and
it's like this whole thing but it isn't
really about that it's just kind of
because they had such an interesting
they were there filming as it all
because the documentary opens up with
kind of like him being arrested and
everyone reacting being like what what
the [__] how did this happen he wouldn't
do it yeah everyone's in denial and it's
just such an interesting look because
you've never ever get to see any kind of
things like this where like every it's
more about the people around him than
him himself yeah and how they're
reacting to this kind of all unfolding
and going from being like no no he would
never do this so were they originally
taking the documentary with the context
of like this is this is crazy dude yeah
right right and obviously they
interviewed him a ton and there's so
much ominous [__] that he said yeah from
these interviews I really feel like
killing someone and he literally
literally he said [__] like that what
and he literally kept being like you
know if you met a psychopath do you want
do you think you would know and he's
just talking about it like that and he's
just like when you watch your back
you're like obviously this guy's on
hinge yeah like obviously when everyone
was around him I was like oh he's a
genius he's a Visionary he's making all
this cool stuff yeah and it's it's just
so fascinating how it you shows the
dichotomy of how
like one moment everyone literally
believes that you're like the smartest
man and the genius and you're just a
[__] crazy dude yeah like you'd
happen to get lucky and people flock to
you and you made some stuff and then
it's someone should keep an eye on you
yeah
making me think more and more about how
we we idolize these really bizarre
people and the bizarre behavior yeah
yeah when it's really a lot of the
majority oh yeah a lot of them are just
like unhinged yeah you know it's obvious
that this guy uh dude and there's some
[__] up stuff like there's one point
in the documentary where
um
one of the interns Masters him and is
like hey I need you to motivate me
because I'm not going to do my work can
you just say you're gonna like you're
gonna like do something violent to me or
something to make me motivated to work I
don't know why
um but he then goes sends her like this
giant essay about how exactly he's going
to kill her and it's actually what he
does later on like to the journalist
it's so [__] and then Christ yeah it's
just all [__] but again it's it's just
so fascinating I recommend watching it
if you really want to
um let me get my Netflix out because I I
should actually do that I'm really bad
remembering the names of shows aren't I
I always do this I never remember the
show's name you know because you've
watched so many I do watch a lot so I
was like it's one of the shows that I've
watched on Netflix I watch the
documentary about the meme guy who
killed you know the ax guy oh I saw that
I watched that too yeah I was gonna
watch that was that one good yeah it's
pretty good actually yeah into the deep
the submarine murder case okay it's it's
an hour and a half really concise gets
to the Point man is it fascinating like
how into the deep was like that sounds
like a clickbait YouTube clickbait title
it's like into the deep that's a good
title that like encapsulates what the
story is about just yeah not clickbait
enough we need murderers dude could you
imagine the subject they're just filming
the life of God and then Gant just
murders someone and you're like what the
[__] you're like wow not a foreshadow
this is a very different documentary now
yeah what the heck yeah that's that's
really interesting yeah that's wow yeah
like I don't recall the time that's ever
happened like where they've been filming
someone just a normal day like filming
them yeah and then they do something
like this I'd like you know because we
get to this is like reality court cases
like stuff that's like this is why I
really respect documentary makers
sometimes they just go into it and
they're like yeah I don't know what
story we're gonna take we're just gonna
take a [__] risk see what happens
story we can make out of this that's why
that's another good point is that that
it was really fascinating watching uh I
wish them a cafe documentary oh about
dude this is the most [__] insane man
on Earth the stories that come out just
just a very mentally ill man yeah um but
what was more interesting is that the
people who are filming him the whole
time they kept talking about it and dude
man the guy who followed John McAfee ran
was basically just a war photographer he
was like yeah dude you got to be this
[__] insane follow a guy like that
because they were like Crossing Borders
illegally and stuff like the film crew
because they're like we want to get this
stuff
we're gonna break the law to get the
footage as well Jesus Christ so like
whenever he did anything batshit insane
the cameraman are doing it too yeah like
when he's illegally breaking it like
Crossing Borders all these cameraman are
doing it too when when he's carrying
guns around illegally they're with them
too right like they take so much risk to
get these like insane shots and stories
and it's so like I just dude I respect
it man like dude anything for the shot
it's insane like these people like War
photographers and War videographers are
the most insane people on earth nature
videographers Yeah man they get like the
most important like footage or uh
pictures that we'll ever like need yeah
for sure I just have so much respect for
documentary Making especially when they
go to that length like that where they
will put themselves in like the most
dangerous situations yeah almost
recklessly you know uh like should
anyone have followed John McCaffrey
around absolutely not but you know I
it's it's interesting getting this but
at least we get to see that side
it's insane someone has to do it to
think that we get to watch that stuff
yeah for sure well it's just like seeing
something like that reminds you what
just like you know pure just pure
journalism is you know for sure when we
think about it it's weird because when
we think about journalism now a lot of
people think [__] either like IGN
articles or just some guy behind a
keyboard who has exposed like a scam or
something like that right but we forget
that there are people who like travel
out like you know areas of conflict War
zones and stuff like that who are like
in real situations of danger and risk
and they do it to get the [__] truth
out and that's [__] insane [__]
Giga Chads right yeah hey have you seen
that like one clip of I think it was
like I don't know if it was like it was
it was a reporter who was in a war zone
she gets shot and then she puts on like
a bulletproof uh vest and it just
continues like reporting yeah even
though she just got shot and I'm like
what a [__] badass can you imagine
she's just like it's just like bang it's
like oh whoops forgot to put this on
that won't happen again I apologies
don't worry about it so that was my uh
my weekly recommendation of uh
documentaries to check out